Pam, you're so pretty.
You are everything.
I had plans to meet a friend tonight, which
I had to cancel, but this is cool too.
I'm not a complainer.
Wow. For the bugs.
Nice. And that's excellent because bugs love
my famous grilled cheese sandwich.
Wow.
Nice. I can't remember the last time someone
made me dinner.
Hey, hey.
We can go. That's fine.
Uh, not a bad day.
You know, you don't have to answer calls
during a party. Um, just thought you should
know.
No, I was just, um, checking out my present.
But I traded with Dwight.
Um, just. I figured, you know, you went to a
lot of trouble, and it means a lot.
And also, Roy got me an iPod, or, uh, was
going to get me an iPod, so.
Well, either way, this is an amazing gift
because it comes with bonus gifts.
Look inside.
Oh my God.
The yearbook
picture. Yeah, I think I made the right
choice.
Oh my God.
It's incredible.
Is this the boggle timer?
I didn't think you were gonna get that one.
I really did, not that one.
I do not think that is funny.
Jinx. Buy me a Coke.
Oh, no no, no no talking.
Jim is not allowed to talk until after he
buys me a Coke. Those are the rules of jinx,
and they are unflinchingly rigid.
Sold out.
That is never happened in the history of
jinx. Sorry, that's not my problem.
Quick. So I guess I'll see you in ten hours.
What are you gonna do with your time off?
Travel? Yeah, I've been looking forward to
it. It's gonna be.
Really nice. I'm gonna find myself.
Do you have new music? Yeah.
Definitely.
I did the coal walk.
Just. I did it, Michael.
You couldn't even do that.
Maybe I should be your boss.
Wow. I feel really good right now.
Why didn't any of you come to my art show?
I invited all of you.
That really sucked.
It's like sometimes some of you act like I
don't even exist.
Jim, I called off my wedding because of you,
and now we're not even friends.
And things are just, like, weird between us.
And that sucks.
And I miss you.
You're my best friend before you went to
Stanford. And I really miss you.
I shouldn't have been with Roy.
And there were a lot of reasons to call off
my wedding. But the truth is, I didn't care
about any of those reasons until I met you.
And now you're with someone else, and that's
fine. It's whatever.
That's not what I'm. I'm not okay.
My feet really hurt.
The thing that I'm just trying to say to
you, Jim, and to everyone else in the
circle, I guess, is that I miss having fun
with you. Just you.
Not everyone in the circle.
Okay, I am going to go walk in the water
now. Yeah, it's a good day.
Pam. That was amazing.
But I am still looking for someone with a
sales background.
We're friends and I'm sure we'll stay
friends. We just.
We never got the timing right.
You know, I shot him down, and then he did
the same to me, and.
But you know what? It's okay.
I'm totally fine.
Everything is going to be totally fine.
Sorry. Um, are you free for dinner tonight?
Yes. All right then, it's a date.
I'm sorry. What was the question?
Margaret, I know you just got yourself kicked
out of your apartment.
Oh, I don't care. I don't really like that
place that much anyway. I'll just move.
Oh, really? Who's gonna take you in?
You're messy. You're a klutz.
You spill everything, and you leave the
volume on the TV way too loud.
Yeah.
Maybe I'll just move in with my boyfriend
because he's kind of a slob, too.
Okay, sure. Let's do it.
No, I, um, well, I'm not gonna.
I'm. I'm not going to move in with anyone
unless I'm engaged.
Have I not proposed to you yet?
I don't know.
Oh, no.
Well. That's coming.
Oh. Right now.
No, I can't do it right here.
That would be rather lame.
Okay, so then when.
Pam, I'm not going to tell you.
I hate to break it to you, but that's not
how that works.
Oh, right.
Yeah.
Wait. I'm serious.
It's happening.
Okay.
And when it happens, it's going to kick your
ass, Beesly.
So stay sharp.
I've been warned.
I am not kidding.
Got it a week after we started dating.
What have we got here?
Good pizza. Yeah.
Cheese. Or do we have other flavors or
different stuff? Which one's this?
Perfect. Do you remember what you said to me
on my first day at work?
Just before you walked me over to my desk?
Yeah.
Enjoy this moment, because you're never going
to go back to this time before you met your
desk mate, Dwight.
And that's why I knew you.
You came up to my desk and you said, this
might sound weird, and there's no reason for
me to know this, but that mixed berry yogurt
you're about to eat has expired.
That was the moment that you knew you liked
me. Yep.
Wow. Can we make it a different moment?
Nope.
I did something bad.
Huh? I stole this for you, Pam.
You took me.
By the hand.
Maybe up there that one night.
One night.
My veil tore.
I knew when we were getting married and I'm
five months pregnant, that I'm not going to
be able to wear the dress that I always
wanted or high heels.
Hey.
You look just as I imagine you.
Pam, you're so pretty.
Yeah.
Thank you.
Who cares? It's a stupid veil, right?
No.
This is the one thing I was supposed to be
able to control. Was this veil.
There. Now we're even.
Is it? Is it pebbles from
that beach in Jamaica?
Oh, go easy with the shaking.
Oh my God.
Well, you like it.
I love it.
Yeah, I do make great Christmas gifts, but I
couldn't make that.
All right, my turn.
Oh, um. It's just I didn't I didn't have a
lot of time, so that's just a placeholder,
right? Of course.
The Adventures of Jimmy Halpert.
Oh, my God, this is awesome.
That's my bike.
That's my desk and that is my daughter.
I mean.
Just you and me.
Let go! Yeah.
Oh, yeah.
Like that.
Oh, there we go.
You got it.
Five tickets on the windshield.
Hey. Hi.
We did it.
You used my move, didn't you?
I used a variation of your move.
It was like
a little gentle.
Deep jolt. To be honest, I still can't
believe he didn't call her back.
Who doesn't call a dork like that back?
Oh, wow.
Spinach in a can.
Power from spinach.
Ga GA GA GA GA GA GA.
Oh my hero.
All right, I'm going to go warm up the car.
Okay, okay.
Oh, you dropped something, Jim.
Okay, I know I've been crying easily today,
but. I mean, that's just pretty killer,
right? I mean, maybe it's stupid.
No.
It's wonderful.
I'm going to frame it.
I can always unframe.
Oh, you saved this.
And I won't waste a minute without you.
You watched it?
Yeah.
Well, then I guess you're ready for this.
What's that? It's from the teapot.
Everything you'll ever need to know.
Is in that note
. Not enough for me.
You are everything.
Thank you.